This is 99% Invisible. I'm Roman Mars. It's the end of the year in time for our annual mini stories episodes. Mini stories are these fun, quick hit stories that maybe came up in our research for another episode or they're just some cool thing that someone told us about. It could be from a friend, someone on Twitter, a relative, Avery's dad, some story that we found really interesting, but it didn't quite warrant a full episode in two months of hard reporting, but there are great 99PI stories nonetheless.
这里是《99%隐形》。我是罗曼·马尔斯。又到岁末，迎来了我们一年一度的迷你故事特辑。迷你故事是一些有趣、节奏明快的短篇，它们可能是在我们调研其他单集时偶然发现的，也可能只是别人跟我们讲的一些酷事。它可能来自朋友、推特上的某个人、亲戚、埃弗里的爸爸，或者我们觉得非常有趣、但又不足以支撑两周艰苦报道做成完整单集的某段故事，但它们依然是精彩的99PI故事。
And my favorite part is we do them as unscripted interviews where I'm in the studio, but the people who work on this show, who I like a lot. This is the greatest team in all the podcast land. I guarantee you that. This week we have stories about 60s called TV shows, semi-useless gadgets, woo-woo miracle cures, in a modern Christmas tradition. It's gonna be fun. Up first is Avery Trollfun. Okay.
而我最喜欢的部分是，我们以非即兴采访的形式来做这些故事，我就在录音室里，和那些我非常喜欢的制作节目的伙伴们在一起。这是整个播客界最棒的团队。我向你保证。本世纪我们准备了关于60年代酷炫电视剧、半无用小发明、伪科学奇迹疗法，以及现代圣诞传统的故事。这会很有趣。首先登场的是埃弗里·特罗尔芬。好的。
Okay. What do you got? I have for you my oldest article of clothing. I am interested. Yeah. I've worn this my whole life. You can feel. I can feel it soft.
好的。你有什么？我为你准备了我最旧的一件衣物。我很感兴趣。是的。我穿这件衣服一辈子了。你可以摸摸。我能感觉到，它很软。
It is a soft gray t-shirt. I've been wearing that weirdo shirt since I was like three. So clearly my parents gave it to me. I mean, I definitely remember it went down to your knees. Well, why you took it, I don't know, or maybe I get it, I don't know. I don't think I had the agency to take it. I bet you put it on me.
这是一件柔软的灰色T恤。我从大概三岁起就一直穿着这件奇怪的衣服。所以很显然是我父母给我的。我的意思是，我绝对记得它长得盖过你的膝盖。好吧，你为什么拿了它，我不知道，或者也许我懂，我不知道。我觉得我当时根本没有主动拿它的能力。我敢打赌是你把它穿到我身上的。
The shirt is 25 years old. I don't really, at least 25 years old. This is my dad, the giver of this shirt to me. So I read what it's on it? Yes, read what's on it. Okay. Where am I in the village? What do you want?
这件衣服有25岁了。我真的……至少有25岁了。这是我爸爸，这件衣服的赠予者。那我读一下上面写的东西？对，读一下上面写的东西。好的。我在哪个村子里？你想要什么？
Information. Who side do you want? That would be telling. We want information. Information. Information. You won't get it. By hooker by crook, we will.
情报。你站在哪一边？无可奉告。我们要情报。情报。情报。你得不到的。不择手段，我们会得到的。
We will. Sorry, I have to scroll down. It's scroll down to the shirt. It's a real life. Okay, here we go. Okay, get serious. I'll give my serious voice on. Who are you?
我们会得到的。抱歉，我得往下滚动。向下滚动到这件衣服。这是真实生活中的……好的，我们开始。好的，严肃点。我要拿出我的严肃声音了。你是谁？
The new number two. Who is number one? You are number six. I am not a number. I am a free man. I am not a number. I am a free man. I am not a number. I am a free man. I know what this is. What is it, Roman?
新的二号。谁是一号？你是六号。我不是编号。我是自由人。我不是编号。我是自由人。我不是编号。我是自由人。我知道这是什么。这是什么，罗曼？
This is a t-shirt from the prisoner. And my dad's going to help us explain what the prisoner is. The prisoner was an extraordinary television series made, I think, in 1966. And it was during the 60s when you had the whole James Bond secret agent, you know, saying. So the prisoner is a 1960s TV show about a British spy, played by Patrick McGuin, who mysteriously resigns and then that evening is abducted and he finds himself in this mysterious place called the village. The village is this odd little town. He doesn't know where it is, he doesn't know what it is, that it's just a very strange little
这是一件来自《囚徒》的T恤。我爸爸将帮我们解释什么是《囚徒》。《囚徒》是一部非凡的电视剧，我想制作于1966年。那是60年代，当时到处都是詹姆斯·邦德那样的秘密特工，你知道的那种口头禅。所以《囚徒》是20世纪60年代的一部电视剧，讲述了一位英国间谍，由帕特里克·麦克古汉饰演，他神秘辞职，然后在当晚被绑架，发现自己身处一个名为“村子”的神秘地方。“村子”是一个奇怪的小镇。他不知道它在哪里，不知道它是什么，它只是一个非常奇怪的
place. So the village, like it's very disorienting because it seems to be kind of removed from all other countries in the world. There are like castles and villas and townhouses and they're all smashed together and it could be absolutely anywhere and it's completely beautiful and perfect, but like too perfect. Everything is relentlessly cheerful. And everybody has to, you know, good afternoon. We're having a parade.
地方。所以这个村子，让人非常迷失方向，因为它似乎与世界上所有其他国家都隔绝了。那里有城堡、别墅和联排别墅，它们全都挤在一起，它可能绝对在任何地方，而且它完全美丽完美，但又过于完美。一切都无休止地欢快。每个人都得，你知道的，下午好。我们在游行。
So there are all kinds of mandatory parades and events and festivals and no one has names and everyone goes by a number. And again and again, the spy, now known only as number six, has no idea who imprisoned him in this relentlessly cherry place where the people are wearing peppy striped shirts and suits with white piping and they're wearing rainbow capes and kegg sneakers. But the greeting from everybody is be seeing you. Be seeing you which on one hand sounds very inoculated see you later meant was not see you later, it means that we're watching you. Come one, come one, see you. So the whole village is under constant surveillance
所以有各种各样的强制游行、活动和节日，没有人有名字，每个人都用编号代称。一次又一次，这位现在只被称为“六号”的间谍，完全不知道是谁把他囚禁在这个无休止欢快的地方，那里的人们穿着精力充沛的条纹衬衫、带白色滚边的西装，还穿着彩虹斗篷和凯兹运动鞋。但每个人的问候都是“后会有期”。“后会有期”一方面听起来像是非常无害的“回头见”，但其实并不是“回头见”，它的意思是“我们在监视你”。来吧，来吧，看着你。所以整个村子都处于持续监控之下
all the time. And in every episode, the members of the village are trying to break number six, and they put him through elaborate mind games and challenges and temptations, trying to figure out why he resigned. And the spy can't leave the village, or a giant weather balloon will come after him and smother him.
随时随地。在每一集里，村子的成员都试图击垮六号，他们让他经历精心设计的心理战、挑战和诱惑，试图弄清楚他为什么要辞职。而且间谍无法离开村子，否则一个巨大的气象气球就会追上来并将他窒息。
And the show only lasted like 17 episodes or so and it was really crazy. James Bond meets Dr. Who. On acid. Yeah. The show gets weirder and weirder with each progressing episode, right? Yes, it eventually sort of went off the rails.
这部剧只播了大约17集左右，真是太疯狂了。詹姆斯·邦德遇上《神秘博士》。吸了毒的那种。是的。随着每一集的推进，这部剧变得越来越诡异，对吧？是的，它最终有点彻底失控了。
Did everybody just went crazy? So the very last episode doesn't make any logical sense. It's completely crazy. But at the beginning of this bonkers absurdist crazy episode was something that my dad found truly shocking. At the beginning of the opening very last episode, they reveal the location of the village in real life. And just like, oh my God, this place really exists.
每个人都发疯了吗？所以最后一集在逻辑上完全说不通。完全是疯了。但是在这个极其荒诞疯狂的最后一集的开头，出现了一件让我爸爸感到真正震惊的事情。在最开始、开场的那最后一集里，他们透露了村子在现实生活中的所在地。然后就觉得，天哪，这个地方真的存在。
What the hell is this place? So the village looks like a set, but it's a real place. And for my whole life, as long as I have been wearing that weird shirt, my dad has wanted to go there. And this year, he finally did. You know, it's in a remote corner of Wales It wasn't easy to get there. Wow. Here's the backstory After World War one there's this Welsh architect name sir Bertram Clough Williams Ellis
这到底是个什么地方？所以村子看起来像个布景，但它是个真实的地方。我一辈子以来——只要我一直在穿那件奇怪的衬衫——我爸爸就一直想去那里。今年，他终于去了。你知道，它位于威尔士的一个偏远角落。去那里并不容易。哇。背景是这样的：第一次世界大战后，有一位名叫伯特伦·克劳·威廉姆斯·埃利斯爵士的威尔士建筑师
And he was kind of dismayed by how the UK was rebuilding after after World War one and all these gorgeous old buildings were the UK was rebuilding after World War I, and all these gorgeous old buildings were getting torn down, or they just weren't bothering to rebuild in the beautiful classical style. They were building big brutalist concrete blocks. And so when he acquired this remote plot of land in 1925 in his home country of Wales, he decided to bring the beauty of the whole of Europe back to his homeland, literally.
他对英国在一战后重建家园的方式感到有些沮丧，那些华丽的老建筑……英国在一战后进行重建，所有这些华丽的老建筑都被拆毁了，或者他们根本懒得用美丽的古典风格进行重建。他们建造的是巨大的粗野主义混凝土块。因此，当他在1925年在自己的祖国威尔士获得这块偏远的土地时，他决定将整个欧洲的美丽带回他的祖国，字面意义上的。
And as Ellis would travel around the world, he'd find a colonate or a building or a church, or maybe the top two floors of a church, dismantle it, ship it to Port Myron, but every British person that I've heard calls it Port Marion. And from 1925 to 1975, Cloth William Ellis, Williams Ellis hunted for all these crumbling remains of castles and houses and villas across the continent, especially the Mediterranean, and rescued them by bringing them to this one spot. And to kind of fund it, it became a resort. I've never seen anything like it because usually when you think of fund it, it became a resort. I've never seen anything like it because usually when you think of hotel, it's a building. But this is 35 buildings in an isolated area. And each building, I mean,
埃利斯在世界各地旅行时，会找到柱廊、建筑或教堂，或者可能是教堂的顶层两层，将其拆卸，运到波特麦林——但我听过的每个英国人都叫它波特梅里恩。从1925年到1975年，克劳·威廉姆斯·埃利斯在整个欧洲大陆（尤其是地中海地区）搜寻所有这些crumbling（正在崩塌的）城堡、房屋和别墅的遗迹，并将它们带到这个地方进行抢救。为了资助这个项目，这里变成了一个度假村。我从未见过这样的地方，因为通常当你想到度假村时，它只是一座建筑。但这是一个占地偏远地区的35栋建筑群。每栋建筑，我是说，
besides, you know, the restaurants and the support thing, it's a, it's a, it's a thing that was like a miniature Disneyland. Except unlike Disneyland, everything's actually real. Right. Like it's all actually old architecture. But apparently, I mean, here I have these books that you can look at pictures of it. These are my dads, my dad's literature. But it still looks quite Disney-esque
除了餐馆和配套设施之外，它是一个……一个类似于微型迪士尼乐园的东西。只不过与迪士尼乐园不同，一切都是真实的。对吧。就像它全都是真正的古建筑。但显然，这里有这些书你可以看看上面的图片。这些是我爸爸的，我爸爸的读物。但它看起来依然非常像迪士尼风格
because it's all painted, these bright colors. Yeah, it really does. I mean, I would have never thought it was real from what I've seen of it. Yeah. That's crazy. It's almost like, why would you go to the effort of doing it for real? When it looks so fake. But it does remind me that when we look at old architecture, we expect to see the weathering of it. And if you really do restore it, it is bright and shiny and odd and brightly colored and
因为它们都被涂成了这些鲜艳的颜色。是的，确实如此。我的意思是，从我所看到的样子来看，我绝不会认为它是真的。是的。太疯狂了。这简直就像，你为什么费那么大劲去弄个真的？当它看起来那么假的时候。但这确实提醒了我，当我们看古建筑时，我们期待看到岁月的风化。如果你真的去修复它，它是明亮、闪亮、奇特、色彩鲜艳的，
pink and bright yellows and things like that. But like clock Williams Ellis kind of took it a step further because he added, he like added stuff. He put in fake windows that weren't really there. He'd like paint them on. And he added stairways that didn't go anywhere just because he thought they looked scenic and added these windy paths. So he also kind of like turned it into this 2D fruity playground of actual.
粉红色、鲜黄色之类的。但克劳·威廉姆斯·埃利斯有点把这推向了更远的一步，因为他添加了东西。他加入了原本并不存在的假窗户。他会把它们画上去。他还添加了通往虚无的楼梯，只因为他认为这样看起来风景优美，并增添了这些蜿蜒的小路。所以他也某种程度上把它变成了一个真实事物的2D古怪游乐场。
And the cool thing was it was postmodernism before postmodernism. Yeah, totally. Like it looks like a lot of styles that we would recognize now, where they're smashing, you know, colonnades on villas, on gothic clock towers and painting it all bright colors. And so in a weird way, like it must have looked extra crazy in the 60s when no one was doing that. Oh, totally. Although, you know, maybe without having gone through postmodernism, you would just see it as this weird collage, whereas we might now have the language of Disney and cheesy postmodernism
最酷的是，这是后现代主义之前的后现代主义。是的，完全是。就像它看起来像是许多我们现在能认出来的风格，他们把柱廊、别墅和哥特式钟楼拼凑在一起，并把它们涂上鲜艳的颜色。所以从某种奇怪的角度来看，在60年代没有人这么做的时候，它一定显得格外疯狂。哦，完全是。虽然，你知道，也许如果没有经历过后现代主义，你只会把它当作一个奇怪的拼贴画，而我们现在可能有了迪士尼和俗气后现代主义的语言
to apply to this thing. Like maybe it looks cheap to us because of our lived experience of these things, but it might have just felt opulent and amazing to somebody before post-modernism existed. Funny, you say that. Architecture Critics Lewis Mufford wrote in 1964, Port Marion is a gay, deliberately irresponsible reaction against the dull sterilities of so much that passes as modern architecture today. So it was like shocking. No one had seen anything like it.
来套用到这个事物上。就像由于我们对这些事物的实际生活经验，它对我们来说可能显得廉价，但在后现代主义诞生之前，对于某个人来说，它可能只觉得是极其奢华和惊艳的。有趣的是你这么说。建筑评论家刘易斯·芒福德在1964年写道：“波特梅里恩是对当今许多被视为现代建筑的沉闷呆板的一种欢快、刻意不负责任的反抗。”所以这太令人震惊了。没有人见过这样的东西。
And you Frank Lloyd, right, went to visit it. Gregory Pack came to visit. Ingrid Bergman came to visit. Brian Epstein from the Beatles would stay there. Oh. George Harrison stayed there. A lot of British celebrities and stuff would go there because it was so isolated and it was so beautiful.
弗兰克·劳埃德·赖特也去参观过。格利高里·派克来参观过。英格丽·褒曼来参观过。甲乐队的布赖恩·爱泼斯坦会住在这里。哦。乔治·哈里森也住过这里。许多英国名流之类的人都会去那里，因为那里非常偏僻而且非常美丽。
And they treated everybody with a sense of discretion. So it was this place that was kind of separate from the rest of the world and removed from time and context where your name didn't matter. Basically all the stuff that made it unbearable for number six. I was there for the Prisoner Appreciation Society weekend. So you had people walking around. Prisoner costumes and they were reenacting episodes. My dad was there for this thing called Port Maricon, which is basically like a giant cosplay event for the prisoner where everyone they do parades and they pretend to abduct people and there's a giant balloon floating around. Everyone's wearing striped capes and cats except
而且他们对待每个人都带有一种谨慎感。所以这是一个有点与世隔绝、超脱于时间和背景之外的地方，在这里你的名字并不重要。基本上所有让六号感到无法忍受的元素都在这里。我是为了《囚徒》鉴赏协会周末活动而去的。所以你会看到人们到处走动。穿着《囚徒》的戏服，他们还在重现剧中的情节。我爸爸是去参加一个叫“波特玛丽康”的活动，这基本上就像是《囚徒》的大型角色扮演活动，每个人都在进行游行，他们假装绑架别人，还有一个巨大的气球在到处飘浮。每个人都穿着条纹斗篷和猫……除了
my dad. You know, it was a little... A little much. It was a little too much. I enjoyed the spectacle. I wasn't up for the lifestyle. Still, it was kind of cool because this is my dad's favorite show. He loves this show. And so for him, it was kind of visiting an old friend.
我爸爸。你知道，有点……有点过头了。有点太过了。我很享受这种奇观。我可受不了那种生活方式。不过，这还是挺酷的，因为这是我爸爸最喜欢的剧。他超爱这部剧。所以对她来说，这有点像是去拜访一位老朋友。
Because like they tried to remake the prisoner kind of recently. They tried to do an American version of it. It was terrible. It was terrible. I don't know what else to say. It was just terrible. Because my dad says it just can't work without the main star and visionary, Patrick McGuin. He's the one who made it weird. But it also couldn't work without Port Marion. I think if the prisoner were done in like a star trek thing, it wouldn't have worked. What made it so incongruous that you were in this natural environment in these beautiful old buildings. That's what I think made it even more horrifying because it was
因为他们最近又试图翻拍《囚徒》。他们尝试做了一个美国版的。太烂了。太烂了。我不知道还能说什么。就是太烂了。因为我爸爸说，没有了主演兼远见者帕特里克·麦克古汉，它是绝对行不通的。他是那个让这部剧变得诡异的人。但没有了波特梅里恩，它也同样行不通。我想如果《囚徒》是在类似《星际迷航》那种布景里拍的，就绝对不会成功。真正让它如此不协调的是，你身处这种自然环境以及这些美丽的老建筑中。我认为这才是让它更加惊悚的原因，因为它
so pleasant and it was so cute and it was so charming and it was so analog. And so that's the cool thing about the prisoner, and Port Marion itself. It's not trying to be just a tribute to the past or a vision of the future. It's just kind of this like a malgum-mated alternative reality. But in a weird way, in both cases, with Port Marion and the prisoner, they just turned into alternate realities that look like what we have today, which is, you know, postmodernism and Disneyland, and also this like world of constant surveillance and constant cheeriness. It shows that the sort of fantastic nightmare that Maguyn was predicting in some cases is certainly now technologically possible. And that's totally why I still wear the shirt, also because it's soft.
是如此愉快，如此可爱，如此迷人，又如此模拟化。所以这就是《囚徒》和波特梅里恩本身最酷的地方。它不只是想成为对过去的致敬或对未来的展望。它只是一种混合的另类现实。但在某种奇怪的层面，无论是波特梅里恩还是《囚徒》，它们最终都变成了类似于我们今天的另类现实，也就是（你知道的）后现代主义和迪士尼乐园，还有这样一个充满持续监控和持续欢快感的世界。这表明麦克古汉在某些情况下预测的那种奇幻噩梦，在技术上现在绝对是可能的。这绝对就是我至今仍穿着这件衬衫的原因，也是因为它是软的。
It is very soft. That's awesome. Thank you, Afrey. Thanks. You're seeing you. It is very soft. That's awesome. Thank you, Afrey. Thanks. You're seeing you. You're seeing you. Up next, this is producer Vivian Lee. So I'm just remembering right now that the first time you appeared on this show was last years mini stories before you were a staff member at Nine-Ein-Pi. Yeah, it's my 99 P.I.
它确实很软。太棒了。谢谢你，埃弗里。谢谢。后会有期。它确实很软。太棒了。谢谢你，埃弗里。谢谢。后会有期。后会有期。接下来，这位是制作人薇薇安·李。我突然想起，你第一次出现在这个节目上是去年的迷你故事，当时你还不是“99PI”的正式员工。是的，这是我的99 P.I……
That's so nice. This is so great. I'm so happy you're here. And so, what is your mini story as a staff member? Okay. So, I'm going to start this with another question. Okay. So, you travel a lot, right?
太好了。这太棒了。我很高兴你来到这里。那么，作为正式员工，你的迷你故事是什么？好的。所以，我要用另一个问题来开始。好的。你经常旅行，对吧？
I do travel a lot. And you travel a lot, right? I do travel a lot. And you travel with devices, right? Yes. Okay. So have you ever been on the road and one of your batteries runs out of power? Absolutely. The one on the phone, it's like 5 or 6 p.m. consistently. That's the way it is.
我的确经常旅行。你也经常旅行，对吧？我确实经常旅行。而且你旅行时会带电子设备，对吧？是的。好的。那么，你有没有过在路上时，你的某块电池突然没电了？绝对有。手机的那块，基本上每次都是下午5点或6点准时没电。事情就是这样。
Right. Yeah. Oh, yeah. It's the rule. It has to run out of battery. Yes. But how useful would it be if I told you that there was an AC-free battery-powered battery charger that would let you fully charge that one battery and all it needs are 12 batteries of the same type to recharge that one dead battery.
对。是的。噢，是的。这是铁律。它必须得没电。是的。但是，如果我告诉你，有一个无需交流电、靠电池驱动的充电器，能让你把那一块没电的电池彻底充满，而它所需要的仅仅是12节同型号的电池来为那块没电的电池充电，你觉得这有多大用处？
Well, that doesn't sound very useful. That sounds a little wasteful. Yes. It's not useful. But at the same time, it's not entirely unuseless. That's true. It's not entirely, I could still use that thing, that monstrosity that you are describing. Right, so the AC free battery-powered battery charger is something that actually exists.
嗯，听起来没什么用。听起来有点浪费。是的。没什么用。但与此同时，它也不是完全“毫无用处”。确实如此。它并非完全没用，我还是可以用那个东西，也就是你正在描述的那个庞然大物。没错，所以这个无需交流电、靠电池驱动的电池充电器是真实存在的东西。
Wow. And it's one example of something called Chindogu, which is the art of designing nearly useless gadgets. Wow. Okay. So what do you mean exactly by nearly useless? So a chindogu is a very specific type of invention that sets out to solve one particular problem. But it actually ends up causing so much more of an inconvenience that it's almost entirely useless. Right. So in the case of the battery-powered battery charger, you'd technically solve your problem
哇。这就是被称为“珍道具”的事物的例子之一，也就是设计近乎无用小发明的艺术。哇。好的。那你所说的“近乎无用”具体是什么意思？所以，珍道具是一种非常特定类型的发明，它旨在解决某一个特定的问题。但它实际上最终造成的麻烦要大得多，以至于它几乎完全无用。没错。所以就电池驱动的充电器而言，你在技术上解决了
of having one dead battery, but you'd make a much larger problem by draining 12 other batteries. To power it. Yes, exactly. Yeah. So it comes from the Japanese word chin, meaning weird or strange, and dogu meaning tool. So, strange tool. Oh, that's awesome. Okay, so do you have another example? There are literally thousands of them. There's a pair of high heels with training wheels attached to the heels. If you're just learning how to walk in high heels, you have a little bit of a little carrier right there. There's a Zen Kittie litter box, so you can practice the art of sand raking while you're
电池没电的问题，但你却通过耗尽另外12块电池制造了一个大得多的问题。来给它供电。是的，完全正确。是的。所以它源自日语单词“chin”（意为古怪或奇怪）和“dogu”（意为工具）。所以，就是奇怪的工具。哦，太棒了。好的，那你还有其他例子吗？字面意思上，有成千上万个这样的发明。有一双鞋跟上装了辅助轮的高跟鞋。如果你刚学会穿高跟鞋走路，你就在那里有一个小小的载体。还有一个禅宗猫砂盆，这样你就可以在
cleaning up cat crap. But do you want to know what my favorite chindogo is? I absolutely need to know what your favorite chindogu is? I absolutely need to know where your favorite chindogu is. A solar powered flashlight. So you technically could use it, but you wouldn't really actually use it. Yeah, you couldn't possibly use it. So where do these ideas come from?
清理猫大便的同时练习耙沙子的艺术。但你想知道我最喜欢的珍道具是什么吗？我绝对需要知道你最喜欢的珍道具是什么！我绝对需要知道你最喜欢的珍道具是什么！一个太阳能手电筒。所以在技术上你确实可以使用它，但你实际上根本不会去用它。是的，你根本不可能用它。那么这些创意是从哪里来的呢？
And does anyone actually make them are they just ideas? OK, so you could probably tell by the name, but it started in Japan with a man named Kenji Kawakami. Meet Kenji Kawakami, Japan's famous inventor of the useful and absurd his creations range from umbrellas for shoes to hair splash guards to chop sticks with fans. So Kawakami studied aeronautical engineering in college and he's always been interested in engineering and design and he came up with the concept
真的有人制造它们吗，还是它们只是些概念？好吧，你可能从名字就能猜出来，它起源于日本，由一个叫川上贤司的人发起。认识一下川上贤司，日本著名的实用且荒谬发明家，他的创造从鞋子雨伞、防发水面罩到带风扇的筷子应有尽有。所以川上在大学里学习的是航空工程，他一直对工程和设计很感兴趣，并在20世纪80年代的某个时候想出了这个概念
and started making his own creations sometime in the 1980s. But somehow he actually ended up in publishing, which is kind of how Chindogu took off. So what kind of publishing was he doing? Was he publishing these items? No, no. So in the early 90s, he was the editor of a Japanese catalog called Male Order Life, which is one of those
并在20世纪80年代左右开始自己进行创作。但不知何故，他最终进入了出版业，这正是珍道具走红的原因。那么他当时在做什么样的出版？他在出版这些物品吗？不，不是的。所以在90年代初，他是日本一本名为《男装生活》的目录杂志的编辑，这本杂志是那种
home shopping magazines. Right, right. And so there was this one month when he realized there were some spare blank pages in the back. So instead of just leaving them blank, he decided to include some images of these unuselless inventions that he'd been tinkering around in his workshop with.
开始制作自己的发明。但不知何故，他最终进入了出版业，这也是珍道具得以腾飞的方式。所以他当时在做什么样的出版工作？他在出版这些物品吗？不，不。所以在90年代初，他是一本名为《邮购生活》的日本目录杂志的编辑，这正是那种
So, you know, they weren't for sale or anything, but, you know, he thought it'd be just kind of a fun joke to slip in. So he had the solar-powered flashlight, which I mentioned earlier, and also a pair of iDrop glasses, which are essentially a pair of glasses with funnels over the lenses. So you could just put iDrop's in and they'll funnel directly into your eyeballs, like a little hole, so you could just drip right in. Right. And, you know, the readers ended up getting such a kick out of them that, you know, he started putting chindogu's in every issue after that.
家居购物杂志之一。对，对。所以有那么一个月，他意识到后面有一些空闲的空白页。因此，与其让它们白白空着，他决定在其中加入一些他在工作坊里瞎琢磨的“无用发明”的图片。
Right. And so after a few years of doing this, this American journalist and translator named Dan Papia came across it. And he was like, I have to spread this to the rest of the world. And so the two of them together founded the International Chindogu Society and established the Ten Tenants of Chindogu. And so these have rules.
所以，你知道，它们并不是为了出售什么的，但，你知道，他觉得塞进去当个有趣的玩笑挺好的。所以他有了我刚才提到的太阳能手电筒，还有一副滴眼液眼镜，本质上就是一副在镜片上方带有漏斗的眼镜。这样你就可以直接滴入眼药水，它们会像一个小洞一样直接漏进你的眼球，你就可以直接滴进去了。对。而且，你知道，读者们最后觉得这些东西太逗了，以至于，你知道，他从那以后在每一期杂志里都开始加入珍道具。
So what are some of the tenants to make it a truly, a true Chindogu? Okay, so the first rule is that a chindoku has to be almost completely useless. So if you've created something that's actually useful, you failed. You're done. The second rule is that it has to actually exist. So you have to actually build a chindoku. Oh, good. So I was actually wondering this.
没错。所以在这样做几年之后，一位名叫丹·帕皮亚的美国记者兼翻译偶然发现了它。他就觉得：我必须把这个传播到全世界。于是两人共同创立了国际珍道具协会，并确立了珍道具的十大戒律。所以这些是有规则的。
So you can't just make this hypothetical, even like a picture in a mail or a catalog. You actually have to make the thing. Yeah, yeah, it has to be. That's great. It has to be birthed into the world. I like that rule. Yes. Cool.
那么，要成为一个真正、真正的珍道具，有哪些戒律呢？好的，第一条规则是，珍道具必须几乎完全无用。所以如果你创造的东西实际上是有用的，你就失败了。你出局了。第二条规则是，它必须真实存在。所以你必须实际制造出这个珍道具。哦，太好了。其实我刚才就在纳闷这个。
And so the third rule is actually my favorite. It says, inherent in every chandogu is the spirit of anarchy. And then it goes on to say, they represent freedom of thought and action. The freedom to challenge the suffocating historical dominance of conservative utility. So I think I'm getting, so like a little bit of this is an exercise in rebellion for the
所以你不能只做出假设，甚至不能只是一张邮购目录里的图片。你必须亲手把这东西做出来。对，是的，必须得是这样。太棒了。它必须被带到这个世界上。我喜欢这个规则。是的。酷。
Uber designed product that is perfect, that does its job with great efficiency. And it's like, it frees you to have weirdo inventions that don't that function but don't actually function well. Yes. So yeah, we tend to marry utility and design. Right. And they don't have to be. That is totally true. I don't have to be. Yeah, and I mean, it seems a little strange to use absurdist design as a form of anarchy. But before Kawakami got into publishing, he was actually a radical activist in the 60s and 70s. And so the spirit of non-conformity and anti-consumerism is something that's rooted in the concept of chindogu. There's actually a couple other tenants that dictate you can't sell the invention for money, and you also can't patent it because it belongs to everybody.
然后第三条规则其实是我的最爱。上面写着：“每个珍道具的内核中都蕴含着无政府主义精神。”接着它又写道：“它们代表了思想和行动的自由。挑战保守实用主义那令人窒息的历史统治地位的自由。”所以我想我明白了，这有点像是一种对
So chindogas are supposed to be like embodiment of design without the restrictive thread of materialism. And you can tell by the way that he talks about it, like as silly as it kind of appears, he intended them to be fun, like a fun way to change the world. I believe that if everybody shares my idea of changing perceptions, it says the world could change one invention at a time. And so what happened to Chindogu as a movement? What, you know, these big, lofty ideas? Right, right.
完美、高效完成任务的超级设计产品的叛逆练习。这就好像，它解放了你去拥有那些能够运转但实际上运转得不那么好的怪异发明。是的。所以，是的，我们倾向于将实用性与设计结合在一起。没错。而它们不一定非得如此。这绝对是真的。它们不一定非得如此。是的，我的意思是，用荒诞的设计作为一种形式的无政府主义，听起来可能有点奇怪。但在川上进入出版业之前，他实际上是60年代和70年代的激进活动家。因此，这种不墨守成规和反消费主义的精神，是植根于珍道具概念之中的。实际上还有其他几条规则规定你不能把发明拿去卖钱，而且你也不能申请专利，因为它属于所有人。
You know, it did spread internationally. There are Chindogu societies and competitions all over the world. But Colcomi actually ended up putting a bunch of books out with unuseless inventions that he's made over the years or that people have submitted into the Chindogu society. But since one of the tenants is that you can't make money from Chindogu, he actually ended up donating a lot of the money to charity.
所以珍道具应该成为没有物质主义压抑威胁的设计的化身。从他谈论它的方式中你可以看出，尽管它看起来很傻，但他希望它们是有趣的，就像一种改变世界的有趣方式。我相信如果每个人都认同我改变看法的观点，他说，世界就可以通过一次一个发明来改变。那么，作为一场运动的珍道具后来怎么了？那些，你知道的，宏大崇高的理念呢？对，对。
Oh, that's so nice. Yeah, and I. And I. Yeah, no, he's a good guy. But I actually have one of his books here. Oh, cool. That was published originally in 1995. And I, he's a good guy. But I actually have one of his books here that was published originally in 1995. And can you tell me what you see here?
你知道，它确实走向了国际。世界各地都有珍道具协会和比赛。但川上实际上最终出版了一堆书，里面收录了他多年来制作的无用发明，或者人们提交给珍道具协会的发明。但由于其中一条戒律是你不能从珍道具中赚钱，他实际上最终把很多钱都捐给了慈善事业。
It is a camera on a long stick with a plunger to force the shutter of the camera. This is a selfie stick. That is a selfie stick from 1995. It's called a self-portrait camera stick. Do it yourself without a... a... a... a... a... a... a... a... a... a... a... a... a... a... a... a... a... a... a... a... a... a... a... a... a... a... a... a... a... a... a... a... a... a... a... a... a... a... a... a... a... a... a... a... a... a... a... a... a... a... a... a... a... a... a... a... a... a... a... a... a... a... a... a... a... a... a... a... a... a... a... a... a... a... a... a... a... a... a... a... a... a... a... a... a... a... a... a... a... a... a... a... a... a... a... a... a... a... a... a... a... a... a... a... a... a... a... a... a... a... a... a... a... a... a... a... a... a... a... a... a... a... a... a... a... a... a... a... a... a... a... a... a... a... a... a... a... a... a... a... a... a... a... a... a... a... a... a... a... a... a... a... a... a... a... a... a... a... a... a... a... a... a... a... a... a... a... a... a... a... a... a... a... a... a... a... a... a... a... a... a... a... a... a... a... a... a... a... a... a... a... a... a... a... a... a... a... a... a... a... a... a... you, confusing if they don't speak your language, even costly if the third party regards your camera as a gift. With a 57 centimeter telescoping pole, your dilemma is over. Expanding to three times its length for a full shot of you, your companion, and your environs, your only problem will be that all your shots will capture you and the act of holding a pole.
哦，太好了。是的，而且我……而且我……对，不，他是个好人。但我实际上这里有一本他的书。哦，酷。那是最初于1995年出版的。我……他是个好人。但我这里确实有他的一本书，最初于1995年出版。你能告诉我你在这里看到了什么吗？
This is going to come to you in some future of your photo album unless you really like poles. And it's a full on selfie stick. That's amazing. This was and this was 10 years before the patent for the selfie stick came out. Wow. Yeah. So I don't know if Kawakami failed at making a chandogu or if we failed a society because people are still using selfie sticks. I think we failed a society. Thank you, Vivian. That's great. Thank you. So I'm in the studio with Emmett the Cheryl producer here at 99% of visible. How are you doing? Good.
这是一台装在长棍子上的相机，带有一个用来触发相机快门的柱塞。这是一个自拍杆。那是1995年的自拍杆。它被称为“自拍相机棍”。无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需。无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……无需……無需。这些照片会捕捉到你和拿着一根杆子的举动。
How are you running? I. How are you running? I'm good. So what is your mini story today? All right. So my mini story is about blue glass. Oh. And specifically, it's about this strange period in the mid to late 19th century.
你最近怎么样？我。你最近怎么样？我很好。那么你今天的迷你故事是什么？好的。我的迷你故事是关于蓝玻璃的。哦。具体来说，它是关于19世纪中后期这段奇怪的时期。
When people thought that blue glass or the light passing through a blue pane of glass could solve just about any problem You could possibly have and this all goes back to a civil war general general Augustus J. Pleasanton was a Soldier in the civil war and he was a gentleman scientist. He did a lot of reading So this is Jenny Benjamin and she's the curator of the Museum of Vision in San Francisco. Cool, cool place, check it out. And she has looked into this guy general Pleasantin,
当时人们认为蓝玻璃或穿过蓝色玻璃板的光线可以解决你可能遇到的几乎任何问题。这一切都要追溯到一位内战将军，奥古斯都·J·普莱森顿将军，他曾是内战中的一名士兵，也是一位业余科学家。他读了很多书。这是詹妮·本杰明，她是旧金山视觉博物馆的馆长。酷，很酷的地方，去看看吧。她一直在研究这位普莱森顿将军，
and she says that he was kind of this armchair scientist really shooting from the hip. And he had all kinds of wacky scientific theories, but one of them had to do with blue light. And he reasoned that the blue color of the sky, there must be some inherent value to that color. And that blue light was part of like what facilitated the growth of plants and animals
她说他有点像那种纸上谈兵、随心所欲的科学家。他有各种各样的古怪科学理论，但其中一个与蓝光有关。他推断天空的蓝色必然包含某种内在价值。而且蓝光是促进动植物生长的一部分
and in biological processes. So he built Pleasanton, that is built a garden nursery in his backyard with alternating blue planes of glass and he ran a quote experiment to see how well the vegetables would grow. So this is like a greenhouse? Yes, like a green, but I didn't want to use the term greenhouse because it was a blue house. And when she says quote experiment, what is she saying? She's
以及生物过程的一部分。因此普莱森顿建造了一个花园苗 nursery 在他的后院，交替使用蓝色玻璃板，他做了一个所谓的实验来观察蔬菜的生长情况。所以这就像一个温室？是的，就像一个温室，但我不想用温室这个词，因为它是一个蓝色的房子。当她说“所谓”的实验时，她是什么意思？她说
saying, you know, this isn't exactly the most scientific gentleman scientist. But, you know, basically, he was growing grapes inside of this glass house with a certain amount of the windows tinted blue. And, you know, you can kind of imagine what happens next in the story, right? I think so. Pleasanton reports, of course, that his plants grew to incredible size. So then he expanded the experiment, and he created an animal pan. I believe it was for pigs. And he claimed the pigs grew to enormous size, and it was all because of the blue light.
你知道，这不完全是最具科学性的业余科学家。但基本上，他在这个玻璃房里种植葡萄，一部分窗户被染成了蓝色。你知道，你可以想象这个故事接下来会发生什么，对吧？我想是的。普莱森顿报告说，当然，他的植物长得惊人的大。于是他扩大了实验，建造了一个动物围栏。我相信是给猪建的。他声称猪长到了巨大的体型，这一切都是因为蓝光。
That's so great. Yeah, right. It's the breakthrough of the century. Exactly. And so, you know, words starts to get out about these experiments and he actually starts giving talks kind of around around the country, extoling, you know, the virtues of blue light. He even got a patent or he applied for a patent for what he called his serulean process, which
太棒了。是的，对吧？这是本世纪的突破。完全正确。所以，关于这些实验的消息开始传开，他实际上开始在全国各地到处演讲，赞美蓝光的优点。他甚至为他所谓的“蔚蓝工艺”申请了专利，
I love that. And that's a really amazing name. And you know, a court, this is according to him, but he says the patent officer came to his farm. And this is what he supposedly said, if my investigation should establish the variety of your statements, you have made the most important discovery of this century transcending and importance even that of Morse's telegraph, which at best furnished only a means of communication with distant places while your discovery could be brought home to every living object on the planet.
我喜欢这个。这是一个非常棒的名字。你知道，根据他的说法，他声称专利局长来到了他的农场。这就是他所谓的原话：“如果我的调查证实了你所说的话，你就做出了本世纪最重要的发现，其重要性甚至超越了莫尔斯电报，莫尔斯电报最多只提供了一种与远方沟通的手段，而你的发现可以带到星球上的每一个生物身上。
Your patent would be one of the most valuable ever issued in the United States. Wow, that's my tentative praise. Yeah, right, exactly. And he gets the patent. And then he goes on to write a book about this, about how blue light that it's a panacea. And it was touted as a cure all, right? Everything from skin conditions to your eyesight. Also, baldness, insomnia, back pain, more serious diseases.
你的专利将成为美国历史上最有价值的专利之一。”哇，这是我的试探性赞扬。是的，没错，完全正确。他拿到了专利。然后他接着写了一本关于这个的书，讲述蓝光如何成为万灵药。它被吹捧为包治百病的东西，对吧？从皮肤问题到视力。还有脱发、失眠、背痛以及更严重的疾病。
He basically was saying, you know, this can do everything. And the book was really popular. Like, it's a lot of gobbies. And it had all these testimonials in it, people saying, oh, this like made my pig giant or this like cured my paraplegic child or whatever. And so... For about two years, like 1876 and 1877, there was suddenly this huge fad for all things blue.
他基本上是在说，这可以做到一切。这本书非常受欢迎。有很多吹捧。里面有各种各样的证词，人们说“哦，这让我的猪变得巨大”或者“这治愈了我瘫痪的孩子”之类的。所以……在大约两年时间里，即1876年和1877年，突然掀起了对所有蓝色事物的狂热。
Their blue eyeglasses, she showed me a pair of blue eyeglasses from this period at the Museum of Vision. There was blue wallpaper, but the big thing was blue windows. Me too. So people would build like little sun porches and put one blue glass window, you know, thinking that, you know, if you could spend time bathing in the blue light, that that would hear whatever failed you.
有蓝色的眼镜，她在视觉博物馆向我展示了那个时期的一副蓝色眼镜。有蓝色的壁纸，但最主要的是蓝色的窗户。我也是。所以人们会建造类似的小太阳房，装上一扇蓝色玻璃窗，心想如果你花时间沐浴在蓝光中，就能治愈你的任何毛病。
And this has become known as the blue glass craze. And so when did the blue glass craze come crashing down when people realized it didn't work at all? Yeah, yeah, quickly. It lasted a couple years. And the whole time that it was going on, there were people that were kind of poking fun. The same way, happens now when people believe
这被称为“蓝玻璃狂热”。那么，蓝玻璃狂热是什么时候崩溃的，人们意识到它根本不管用呢？是的，很快。它持续了几年。在它发生的整个过程中，都有人在开玩笑。就像现在人们相信
in pseudoscientific things, there were editorials written about these idiots, installing blue glass all through their houses. But the real nail in the coffin was this, you know, scientific American. I mean, it speaks to how widespread it was that scientific American took it upon themselves to like thoroughly debunk it in their pages. So there was a really long article just debunking every aspect of this science. And you know, just to be perfectly clear about this.
伪科学事物时发生的情况一样，当时也有社论痛斥这些在房子里装满蓝玻璃的笨蛋。但真正给予致命一击的是《科学美国人》。我的意思是，这说明它的传播范围有多广，《科学美国人》亲自在他们的版面上对其进行了彻底的揭穿。因此有一篇很长的文章揭穿了这种科学的方方面面。为了把这一点说得绝对清楚，
There is no way that color by itself or colored light is going to cure your eye disease or any disease. Go see your doctor. So are there any of these blue windows left out in the world? Yeah, I asked Jenny that. Are there like remnants of this era that you can see today like windows and buildings anywhere? That is a really good question. I don't know if there are any buildings with blue windows specifically because of this, but I bet it somewhere I would not be surprised
色彩本身或彩色光绝对不可能治愈你的眼疾或任何疾病。去看医生吧。那么世界上还剩下这些蓝色窗户吗？是的，我问过詹妮。你今天还能看到那个时代的遗迹吗，比如任何地方的窗户和建筑物？这是一个非常好的问题。我不知道是否有任何建筑物因为这个原因而专门装有蓝色窗户，但我敢打赌在某个地方，我不会感到惊讶
we could go Chase some down probably If we were to find this mythical house with its window pane it would probably just one blue window Please tell me you found it. Well, okay, so one of the most comprehensive pieces we're writing about this era was by the writer Paul Collins Oh, he's so great. He's like one of my favorites. He's a really good historical writer. Yeah, totally. And he wrote a chapter about Augustus Pleasanton in one of his books. And in the chapter, he talks about himself finding a window,
我们可能会去追寻一下。如果我们能找到这个带有窗玻璃的神话般的房子，它可能只有一扇蓝色窗户。请告诉我你找到了。好吧，关于这个时代，最全面的文章之一是由作家保罗·柯林斯撰写的。哦，他太棒了。他是我最喜欢的作家之一。他是一个非常优秀的历史作家。是的，完全同意。他在他的一本书中写了一章关于奥古斯都·普莱森顿的内容。在那一章里，他谈到了自己在旧金山生活时发现了一扇窗户，
a blue glass window, when he was living in San Francisco. And so I called him up to talk about that. Yeah, I just was looking at houses that I walked along and there was this one with sort of a front or like, perler type of area that had blue glass panes in it. You know, he's not 100% sure that this is from that era. For all I know, that might have just been like
一扇蓝玻璃窗户，当时他住在旧金山。所以我打电话给他聊了聊这件事。是的，我只是看了看我走过的小屋，其中有一座房子前面有一个前廊或类似起居室的区域，里面有蓝色玻璃窗格。你知道，他并不是百分之百确定这是那个时代的。据我所知，那可能只是
some hippie in 1970 that decided that would be a cool thing. But the age of the house was such that it was like the right era for that to have been an original bit of that fat. In the book he talks about how it's between these two gas stations on this one street in sort of the sunset in San Francisco. And so I did some like Google Street View sleuthing. Okay. And so here check it out. So here is the house. And you can see, yeah, these two pains here. I see. And he thinks that this little entryway on the house is one of these sort of sun porches. That's awesome. Yeah, it's pretty cool.
1970年代的某个嬉皮士决定那会是一件很酷的事情。但房子的年龄表明它是那个时代的，可能是一场狂热的原始遗迹。他在书中谈到它位于旧金山日落区某条街道的两个加油站之间。所以我做了一些谷歌街景侦探工作。好的。所以大家看。这就是那座房子。你可以看到，是的，这里的两个窗格。我看到了。他认为房子里的这个小入口就是这些太阳房之一。太棒了。是的，挺酷的。
And you can tell, you know, it's like, it's like a kind of older looking house on the block. It is, yeah, no, it's a Victorian, and it looks like it could be from that era. Right. For sure. And so, you know, I decided to go check it out. Oh awesome.
你可以看出，你知道，它就像是街区上一座看起来比较老的房子。是的，确实如此，这是一栋维多利亚式建筑，看起来可能是那个时代的。确实如此。所以，我决定去看看。哦，太棒了。
One between the shell station and the chevron. Check it out. Oh awesome. One between the shell station and the chevron. See what we can find. No. Oh no. It's gone. It's gone, the house is gone.
在壳牌加油站和雪佛龙加油站之间。去看看吧。哦，太棒了。在壳牌加油站和雪佛龙加油站之间。看看我们能找到什么。不。哦，不。它没了。它没了，房子没了。
No. Oh no. So it was gone. Oh no. So it was gone. The house had been turned into like a condo. So even that picture from Google Street View is out of date. Yeah. And the crazy thing is that that was from 2017.
不。哦，不。所以它消失了。哦，不。所以它消失了。这栋房子已经被改成公寓了。所以连谷歌街景上的那张照片也过时了。是的。疯狂的是，那还是2017年的照片。
So I went there, I was like, really calm. I was like, oh, I'm going to find it. I'm going to like knock on the door and be like, like, hey, like, what do you think about these blue glass? Like, it makes you feel any better. Like, how healthy are you? And I get there. And I also have the blue windows has been torn down
所以我去了那里，我当时表现得很冷静。我想，哦，我要找到它。我要去敲门，然后说，嘿，你觉得这些蓝色的玻璃怎么样？如果它能让你感觉好一点的话。你身体怎么样？然后我到了。我还发现那些蓝色的窗户已经被拆掉了
and now there's a giant box, a huge clear window. It's really ugly. Trying to be nostalgic about architecture and buildings, but this one really looks terrible. And worst of all, the glasses clear. Yeah, clear glass. What a bummer. Yeah.
现在那里是一个巨大的箱子，一个巨大的透明窗户。真的很丑。虽然试图对建筑和房子抱有怀旧之情，但这个看起来真的很糟糕。最糟糕的是，玻璃是透明的。是的，透明玻璃。真扫兴。是的。
So, you know, the story, after my long search, I still have not found a blue glass window, you know, if anyone out there is. If anyone out there has it, I mean, there's got, there's certainly houses that are extant from that area. But I mean, let's know. Right, it seems plausible that someone out there
所以，你知道这个故事，经过我长途跋涉的寻找，我仍然没有找到蓝色的玻璃窗，你知道的，如果外面有人……如果外面有人拥有它，我是说，那个地区肯定还有幸存的房子。但我是说，让我们知道。没错，似乎有人拥有其中一扇窗户
has got one of these windows we can take a look at. That would be awesome. Cool, thank you so much. Yeah, thank you. Up next, we'll have one more Christmas themed mini-story. You're going to want this for your Christmas party banter right after this. Our final mini-story of the day comes from senior producer Katie Mingle. You know I would make it really cozy in here Roman. It's not cozy enough this are three by five box.
我们可以去看看，那太棒了。酷，非常感谢。是的，谢谢。接下来，我们还有一个圣诞主题迷你故事。你一定会在圣诞派对上需要这个谈资。我们今天的最后一个迷你故事来自高级制作人凯蒂·明格尔。你知道的，罗曼，我会把它弄得很温馨。这里还不够温馨，这个三乘五英尺的箱子。
It's actually like so hot in here but just roll with me. Okay, okay. What would make it cozy in here? A fire. I wouldn't recommend starting a fire in here right now, though. Okay, but what we could do, we could go to YouTube and find ourselves a Uelog. Do you want me to go YouTube right now? Yeah, I will. Okay, sure. Just a tiny bit of history, a Uelog is an old term for a certain type of fire that people would burn at Christmas with like a special log.
其实这里面好热，不过你就将就一下吧。好吧，好吧。怎样才能让这里变温馨？生个火。不过，我可不建议你现在在这里生火。好吧，但我们可以做的是，去YouTube上找一个木柴视频。你想让我现在就去YouTube吗？好的，我会的。好吧，当然。简单讲一点历史，木柴视频（Yule log）是一个老词，指人们在圣诞节时燃烧的一种特定火堆，会用那种特别的木头。
Oh, okay. But now often when people talk about you, a you a log, they're talking about like, um, like this. So click on that. Oh, this 10. That first one. 10 hours of crackling logs for Christmas, okay. It's, it does its job. As soon as the fire starts crackling, like it's relaxing.
哦，好吧。但现在人们经常说到木柴视频时，他们指的是像……像这样。所以点那个。哦，这个10。第一个。10个小时的圣诞节噼啪作响的木柴，好的。它起到了作用。火一开始噼啪作响，就让人觉得很放松。
Yeah. Yeah, it's nice. This idea of putting a fireplace on TV so that you could watch it as if you had a fire in your home actually goes back to 1966. Cool. And it started at this little television, local television station in New York City called WPIX. And yeah, it was kind of the brainchild of the station manager, a guy named Fred Throer.
对。是的，很好。把壁炉放在电视上，这样你就可以像家里有火一样看着它，这个想法其实可以追溯到1966年。酷。它始于纽约市一家名为WPIX的小型本地电视台。是的，这是该台站长弗雷德·特罗尔（Fred Throer）的一个创意。
And he, you know how people are always like looking for holiday content. Right. Like we know this from working in radio. And it was really an idea in his head that he wanted to give city dwellers uh... the luxury and the warmth of a you log fire but that didn't have fireplaces in the apartment so that's chip our curries he's he's kind of an amateur historian of this
而且，你知道人们总是寻找节日内容。没错。就像我们做广播所知道的那样。这其实是他脑海中的一个想法，他想给城市居民……提供木柴炉火的奢华和温暖，但他们的公寓里没有壁炉，所以那是奇普·库里（Chip Currier），他有点像是这段历史的业余研究者
original you all log the location for the first shoot of the you log in nineteen sixty six was crazy mansion which was the mayor's residents still is uh... at the time the mayor was john lindsey and he came from permission to come and film the law that the px their filming group and they did but there was a mishap where a spark
最初的木柴视频，1966年木柴视频的第一次拍摄地点是格雷西大厦，也就是市长的官邸，现在仍然是……当时市长是约翰·林德西（John Lindsay），他批准了PX电视台的拍摄小组去拍摄木柴，他们也照做了，但发生了一个意外，一个火花
flew out and it damage the very expensive oriental rug. So yeah, this was like a $4,000 rug apparently and they really messed it up. But anyway, they got their footage, they put it on the air. It was a three-hour long broadcast with a loop of this fire and it would air on Christmas Eve and you'd turn on your TV to channel 11 and it started actually started with like this little kind of Christmas time, you know, special message from someone at the station. The one that I found online, it's just striking because it's
飞了出来，烧坏了非常昂贵的东方地毯。所以，这似乎是一块4000美元的地毯，他们真的把地毯弄坏了。不过不管怎样，他们拍到了镜头，并在电视上播出了。这是一个三小时长的循环火堆广播，会在平安夜播出，你可以把电视调到11频道，其实它开始时带有一个小小的、圣诞节式的、你知道的，来自电台某人的特别信息。我在网上找到的那个，非常引人注目，因为它是
How to put this it's how to put this. It's very Jesus-forward. Let's hear it. And more than any other person in history, Jesus taught us to respect the godliness in ourselves and give it expression by doing God's work in the world. The gifts which we give this Christmas season, as symbols of God's great gift to us, will pass and be forgotten.
该怎么说呢，该怎么说呢。它非常强调耶稣。我们听听。在历史上的所有人中，耶稣教导我们要尊重我们自身的上帝意识，并通过在世界上做上帝的工作来表达它。我们在今年圣诞节送出的礼物，作为上帝赐予我们伟大礼物的象征，终将过去并被遗忘。
But the gift of hope. As God's gift. Wow. And this is a secular UHF style station, right? So it's a sort of local news station. That's amazing. Yeah. So, and then after that message they'd cut to
但希望的礼物。作为上帝的礼物。哇。这是一个世俗的超高频（UHF）风格的台，对吧？所以它有点像当地的新闻台。太惊人了。是的，所以在那个信息之后，他们会切换到
the fireplace which was the the governor's mansion fireplace and the camera would kind of do like a slow zoom like you'd start out seeing like the whole mantle that there were stockings on the mantle and then it in the you know that would slowly zoom in to where you were just seeing the fire. And then for the next three hours they would play Christmas music. It is classic Christmas music from the 1950s and 60s. So yeah, so it's like a lot of orchestral kind of big band stuff. Like people like the Ray Con of Singers, Fred Wearing and the Pennsylvania's
壁炉，那是州长官邸的壁炉，镜头会进行缓慢的变焦，就像你一开始看到整个壁炉架，壁炉架上有长袜，然后你知道的，它会慢慢放大到你只能看到火。然后接下来的三个小时，他们会播放圣诞音乐。这是1950和60年代的经典圣诞音乐。所以，这就像有很多管弦乐式的宏大乐队的东西。就像雷·康尼夫歌手（The Ray Conniff Singers）、弗雷德·沃林和他的宾夕法尼亚人乐队（Fred Waring and the Pennsylvanians）那样的人
Percy Faith. Percy Faith is the King of the U-Log. There's nobody that has more songs in the program than Percy Faith. The King of the U-Log. Yeah, it's on his tombstone. I've always said that the program, if the program aired with a great video of a fireplace and a bigger soundtrack, it would have not have done very well, but it aired with a great soundtrack. Chip loves Christmas music.
珀西·费斯（Percy Faith）。珀西·费斯是木柴视频之王。节目中没有谁的歌曲比珀西·费斯更多。木柴视频之王。是的，这写在他的墓碑上。我一直说，如果这个节目配上很棒的壁炉视频和更大的原声带，它可能不会做得很好，但它配上了一个很棒的原声带。奇普热爱圣诞音乐。
At some point he mentioned his list of top 500 Christmas songs, and I was like, I didn't even know there were 500 Christmas songs little in top. Wow. Yeah. That's great. So yeah, Chip, Chip basically grew up with this ULLOG broadcast. It was a Christmas Eve tradition and Yeah, he and his family used to watch it together even though they actually had a real fireplace. We did actually watch it. We sat and we'd watch the actual program, the actual footage. Yeah, like you would kind of gather around and put it on and you'd all like stare at it. Yeah, oh yeah, we would watch it like it was a real fireplace.
在某个时候，他提到了他的前500首圣诞歌曲清单，我当时想，我甚至不知道有500首圣诞歌曲，更不用说前500首了。哇。太棒了。所以，奇普基本上是听着这个木柴视频广播长大的。这是平安夜的传统，是的，他和他的家人过去常常一起看，尽管他们实际上有一个真正的壁炉。我们确实看了。我们坐下来看实际的节目，实际的画面。是的，就像你会聚在一起把它打开，然后你们都盯着它看。是的，哦，是的，我们看它就像看真正的壁炉一样。
You know, we actually between the two. It would be on one side of the room, the TV, with the fireplace, with the U-Log, and the other side in our family room was the real fireplace and we were probably watching the you log more than we were the real fireplace. So New Yorkers love this broadcast and eventually the station decides they need to to reshoot it because the film that they shot it on is is deteriorating and it was actually a 17-second loop. Oh my god. People could see. Totally. You can totally see a 17-second
你知道，我们实际上在这两者之间。电视机带着壁炉，带着木柴视频，会在房间的一侧，而我们家庭室的另一侧是真正的壁炉，我们可能看木柴视频的时间比看真正壁炉的时间还要多。所以纽约人喜欢这个广播，最终电视台决定重新拍摄，因为他们拍摄的胶片正在退化，而且实际上这是一个17秒的循环。天哪。人们可以看到。完全可以。你完全可以看到一个17秒的
loop. That's crazy. I know. So but you remember how like the first time they shot it they they like burned the whole in the governor's rug. Well, he did not forget. Yeah. They would not let them back at Gracie Mansion because on the mishap with the rug, how they needed, they needed an location. So yeah, he wouldn't, he wouldn't let them go back there. And somehow, and this part is kind of lost a history. Someone found a very similar looking fireplace and you'll never guess where it was. They located a very close to similar fireplace in California of all places in Palo Alto and they re-filmed it in August of 1970 during a heat wave in Northern California.
循环。太疯狂了。我知道。所以，你还记得他们第一次拍摄时，他们烧了州长地毯上的洞吗？好吧，他没有忘记。是的。由于地毯的事故，他们不会让他们回到格雷西大厦，他们需要一个新地点。所以，是的，他不会让他回到那里。不知何故，这部分历史有点失传了。有人找到了一个看起来非常相似的壁炉，你永远不会猜到它在哪里。他们在加利福尼亚州帕洛阿尔托的一个意想不到的地方找到了一个非常相似的壁炉，并于1970年8月在北加利福尼亚的一次热浪中重新拍摄了它。
Whoa, Bay Area Zone. Palo Alto, California. Take that, New Yorker. That's awesome. And so New Yorkers have been watching our fireplace for 30 years or something. Yeah, so this Palo Alto fire became the Uelog. It aired for 20 years.
哇，湾区。加利福尼亚州帕洛阿尔托。接招吧，纽约人。太棒了。因此，纽约人一直在看我们的壁炉30年左右。是的，所以这个帕洛阿尔托的火堆成为了木柴视频。它播出了20年。
It's the classic Uelog, not to be confused with the original you'll log. The 1966 you'll log that was shot at Grace, you mentioned that air for those first four years is the original, but it's not the classic because most people don't remember those original years that it aired. Wow. So yeah, this one aired for a really long time, so. 20 years.
这是经典的木柴视频，不要与最初的木柴视频相混淆。1966年在格雷西拍摄的那个木柴视频，在前四年播出的那个是最初的，但它不是经典的，因为大多数人并不记得最初播出的那些年。哇。所以，这个播出了很长时间，所以。20年。
Yeah. But then in 1990, Christmas comes and Chip turns on his TV just like he did every year and he turns channel 11 and it just wasn't on. We were all looking forward. It was on. Luckily for me, I just had a feeling that they might not be off forever and I recorded it. So yeah, Chip had had a recording. So he he was fine but the rest of New York was just out of luck and people were mad the station got a ton of letters so why did they take it off the air after twenty years so the station got actually got a new program director the new program director came in and and said what's this
是的。但在1990年，圣诞节来了，奇普像往常一样打开电视，他打开11频道，但它就是没有播。我们都很期待。它播出了。幸运的是我，我只是有一种预感，他们可能不会永远停播，所以我把它录了下来。所以，是的，奇普有一份录像。所以他没事，但纽约的其他人都很不走运，人们很生气，电视台收到了大量的信件，为什么他们在20年后把它停播了，所以电视台其实换了一个新的节目总监，新的节目总监进来后说，这是什么
the log it's taken up too much commercial time you know take it off oh screwed heartless so so yeah so chip and a few other people actually started a the log it's taken up too much commercial time you know take it off uh... heartless so so yeah so chip and a few other people actually started a petition to get it back on the air they set up a website called bringback the log dot com but yeah but nothing seemed to persuade the station that it was worth bringing back until actually nine eleven what happened is after the terrorist attacks beddie Ellen Burlimino, who was the president
木柴视频？它占用了太多的商业时间，把它拿掉吧。哦，冷酷无情。所以，是的，奇普和其他几个人实际上发起了一个……木柴视频？它占用了太多的商业时间，把它拿掉吧……冷酷无情。所以，是的，奇普和其他几个人实际上发起了一个请愿书，要求它重新播出，他们建立了一个名为“把木柴视频带回来”的网站（bringbackthelog.com），但是，没有什么似乎能说服电视台它值得带回来，直到911事件。发生的事情是在恐怖袭击之后，当时电台的总裁
of the station at the time, felt New Yorkers needed comfort food television. They needed something to remind them of the past, something of, you know, more simple, happier days. So yeah, they put it back on, and it still runs today. It runs, I believe it's an hour on Christmas Eve and then a few hours on Christmas Day. Chip believes very strongly that the best time to watch it is Christmas Eve. And the way he talks about it, it's like spiritual for him.
贝蒂·埃伦·布里尔米诺（Betty Ellen Beriliano）觉得纽约人需要舒适的电视节目。他们需要一些东西来提醒他们过去，一些更简单、更快乐的日子的东西。所以，是的，他们把它重新播出了，今天它仍在播放。它在平安夜播放一个小时，然后在圣诞节播放几个小时。奇普坚信观看它的最佳时间是平安夜。当他谈到它时，对他来说就像是精神上的寄托。
It's like Christmas Eve mass. It's like a vigil, so to speak. But the cards are sent, cookies are baked, the gifts are wrapped, and now it's just time to relax and enjoy the solemnity of the moment, enjoy the peace and tranquility of Christmas before the crazy Christmas rush on Christmas day. That's nice. Yeah. Is it the same Palo Alto fire? Did they from something new? I believe they're still using that same Palo Alto fire. Yeah, so that's Chippa Curry. He runs the Bring Back the Log turned into just the
就像平安夜弥撒。可以说就像是一场守夜。但是卡片寄出去了，饼干烤好了，礼物包好了，现在是时候放松一下，享受那一刻的庄严，在圣诞节疯狂的圣诞热潮之前，享受圣诞节的和平与宁静。那很好。是的。这是不是同一个帕洛阿尔托的火堆？他们是从什么新的东西开始的吗？我相信他们仍然在使用那个帕洛阿尔托的火堆。是的，这就是奇普·库里。他经营着把木柴视频带回来网站，变成了
Yoolog.com and he's basically the keeper of all things Yoolog and he even helped the TV station add another hour of music to the broadcast because he has this huge Christmas record collection. And a shout out to our own Avery Treffleman who first told me about this history and to her dad who I think told her. Oh, that's so cool. Wow, that you will log. We'll hear more mini stories from the rest of the 99 PI crew as the first episode of 2019, but we will have episodes in the feed for the final two Tuesdays of 2018, even though
Yoolog.com，他基本上是所有木柴视频相关事物的守护者，他甚至帮助电视台在广播中增加了一个小时的音乐，因为他有大量圣诞唱片收藏。向我们自己的艾弗里·特雷弗曼（Avery Truffelman）致敬，她首先向我讲述了这段历史，还有她的父亲，我想是他告诉她的。哦，太酷了。哇，那个木柴视频。在2019年的第一期节目中，我们将听到来自99%无形（99 PI）其他成员的更多迷你故事，但在2018最后两个星期二，我们的节目源中仍然会有节目，尽管
they land on Christmas Day and New Year's Day. I figured there's a good portion of you who are traveling and resting but still need nice things to listen to while you might have some time off work and if you don't have time off work, we'll still be here for you. So stay tuned and happy New Year! 99% Invisible is Avery Trollfumman, Katie Mingle, Kurt Colstad, the Lany Hall, Sheree Fusef, Emmett Fitzgerald, Sean Riel, Taren Mazza, Joe Rosenberg, Vivian Lee, Sophia Klatsker, and me Roman Mars. We are a project of 91.7 KALW in San Francisco and produced on Radio Row in beautiful downtown
它们正好落在圣诞节和元旦。我想你们中有很大一部分人在旅行和休息，但当你们有一些不上班的时间时，仍然需要好听的东西来听，如果你没有时间休息，我们仍然会在这里陪你。所以请继续关注，新年快乐！99% Invisible（99%无形）由艾弗里·特雷弗曼、凯蒂·明格尔、库尔特·科尔斯特ッド、德兰妮·霍尔、谢里·菲塞夫、埃米特·菲茨杰拉德、肖恩·雷尔、塔伦·马扎、约瑟夫·罗森伯格、薇薇安·李、索菲亚·克拉茨克和我罗曼·马尔斯制作。我们是旧金山 91.7 KALW 的一个项目，在美丽的奥克兰市中心电台街制作
Oakland, California. you There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
奥克兰，加利福尼亚州。你这个剧集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子来发表评论。